for instance School of Economics okay
hello thank you very much to the
organizers for having me it's very
exciting for me to be at this sort of
multi interdisciplinary event I
typically only present this stuff on a
micro econ theorist so I present in a
very institutionalized way so I'm
delighted to be at this broader audience
and and getting feedback from you guys
so I just came off the job market this
is my job market paper aisle I'm gonna
give you a sink sink version of it so
I'll be talking about ratings design and
barriers to entry so you know typically
I'll start with a long motivation about
why we should care about this stuff at
this conference I could have synced it
sunk the entire first two slides I mean
I think we're all on the same page that
online platforms a ubiquitous and very
important these days okay so I'm
focusing on these sort of rating
platforms Yelp and Expedia are good
examples for services right MDS for
medical doctors so you know upwards of
80 % of patients now check their doctors
ratings before deciding whether to have
a to choose them or not d'amato is a
restaurant platform so as we've heard
throughout the day I'm delighted the car
is before me with Susan I mean this is
you know well-known now the welfare
gains that have accrue to the market as
a result of these platforms coming
online okay so on the one hand they
reduce friction z' like search frictions
so they allow trade accountabilities to
discover each other more efficiently and
on the other hand so this is going to be
the focus in my paper they reduce
informational frictions okay so in
particular by providing consumers with a
host of previously generated feedback
they allow consumers to make informed
product decisions okay so this is a firm
on Yelp I'm not sure it's terribly
visible for those of you at the back so
it's got a four star rating but very
importantly after over four and a half
thousand reviews okay so potentially a
lot of information there to help
consumers make their choice now of
course the problem for the new entrant
down the road is very different okay
they have a high rating they only have
three reviews at the moment okay so it
might be that maybe just after a handful
of bad reviews some of which were bad
luck possibly faced with the choice
between these two options consumers
flock to the incumbent instead okay and
this is sort of based simply on expected
quality okay
as a consumer I look at the four stars
and I combine it with four thousand
reviews I think this place is great
whereas I look at full sells after eight
reviews I don't really know much about
it so the expected quality is still
pretty low alright now I haven't haven't
screened it yet so for the new entrant
if the situation is really untenable it
might shut down after a very short
period of time okay and what's worse
they might see all of this coming and
think why on earth should I sync the
enormous fixed costs of setting up my
restaurant and buying all the capital
equipment I might not even bother
entering the market in the first place
okay so this is the story that's going
to be at the heart of my analysis it's
this it's this combination of incomplete
information regarding the products that
these firms have combined with this
user-generated feedback in these
platforms giving rise to a barrier to
entry to new firms in these markets okay
and of course as we've heard throughout
the day the problem here would be that
if high quality firms and not
participating in the market this is
ultimately to the jet you know to the
detriment of overall surplus and welfare
in the platform so this is this sort of
story that I've just given you with
these firms is intimately related to
what we call the problem of the cold
start problem so you know this is when
new products in their lifecycle have a
difficult time getting sampled at the
beginning because people don't want to
use the product they don't know much
about it they get stuck in this sort of
reputational trap okay they can't update
their profile and they don't get sampled
and then they just get stuck okay the
sort of novel aspect of my analysis here
is going to be in seeing how the cold
star problem gives rise to an endogenous
distribution of qualities okay via the
exit and entry choices of the firms that
are populating the market okay so
my previous speakers have you know
talked about this very eloquently the
entry margin turns out to be super
relevant okay so there's a bunch of
empirical papers looking at this problem
this recent JP paper quantifies the
effects of subsidizing entry costs for
firms in a market that have very similar
features to the one I'm looking at sort
of uncertain product quality and they
find the welfare benefits are enormous
okay so this margin is is empirically
very relevant great so just a bit more
focus so these are the two questions
that I'm focusing on firstly how to
consumer reviews shape the dynamic
incentives for firms to participates in
these markets and secondly how should
these platforms design their rating
systems okay so it is going to be a
design problem in the heart of my
analysis is going to be designing
ratings in order to incentivize market
participants okay so as if I haven't
tried to motivate this enough these are
just a couple of quotes from the
d'amato's online blog showing there at
least that they're thinking about these
problems very very carefully so so the
first question they say the penalty from
a bound review could have been a death
sentence especially for a new place as
the low rating may prevent new customers
from visiting the restaurant okay so
this is sort of elucidating this cold
star problem that I was mentioning
secondly on the design related question
they say while we have placed very heavy
focus on helping our users discover
great food one of our core missions for
the next decade is to ensure the
long-term success of restaurants okay so
thinking about long-run outcomes but
crucially both sides with the marketer
coming into their that their platform
design okay so before I get to the to
the model I briefly just want to go
through the the setting that we're going
to find ourselves in and just highlight
the key results so my this is a very
theoretical exercise there'll be one
empirical graph but 99% theory okay so
I'm gonna build a model it's gonna have
firms who make an entry and exit choice
they have a hidden quality and crucially
the quality is going to be gradually
revealed via
consumer feedback consumer
okay so for each firm then we're going
to have associated this rating and the
rating is going to be indicative of the
underlying quality of the firm okay so
consumers are gonna use these ratings
for the different firms out there to
help guide their product choice I'll
obviously be a lot more specific on the
details when I get to get to the model
but that's the basic skeleton of the
model so the first part I'd want to talk
through the positives theory so this is
basically in a benchmark where I assume
all information is available to everyone
every consumer review that's generated
for a firm is just posted automatically
by the platform okay so I'm gonna
characterize this equilibrium uniquely
and show existence also I'll talk a bit
about some of the more interesting
empirical predictions that the model
generates just as as a way of validation
but the focus is going to be on the
normative theory okay so this is where I
look at this the second best problem of
designing the ratings process for firms
in order to shape market outcomes okay
and so the rule the simple takeaway from
the entire exercise is that censorship
policies can dominate transparent
ratings okay to be more specific what's
going to be optimal is if I suppress
incoming reviews for the highest-rated
firms in the platform okay so I stopped
these well established incumbents from
gaining more reviews and building a
strong incumbency position than
themselves okay the economic logic is
going to be by doing this I'm going to
make it easier for new entrant firms to
start making profits earlier in their
lifecycle and that's going to stimulate
entry and overall be beneficial to the
platform okay so that's the basic
mechanism so you know the contribution
here is really a theoretical
contribution in in seeing how we can do
ratings design information design to
shape outcomes of the sort of industry
level okay whereas typically the
literature is focused on a couple of
agents or or smaller settings okay at
least in ego so like I said there is an
empirical part of the paper I'm going to
almost entirely skip over
I'm happy to talk moral flying about it
that is but that that is certainly a
potential of I'll I mean once I
discussed the optimal thing we couldn't
talk more about how that fits in but
yeah I think I'll tell you the model
before you decide whether that's better
or worse okay
great any more questions before I delve
into the model okay so I'm going to be
in continuous time and I'm going to be
looking at steady-state
equilibria of the system my firm's are
going to have two different hidden types
okay so they can either be good or bad
okay and crucially the beginning when
they enter the system neither the firm
nor the market knows about this quality
okay so we're not like in a world which
is typically in in in labor markets and
occupational licensing where people know
they're they're tight before they enter
here's one where the firm doesn't know
whether they've come up with a good idea
or not okay so the restaurant comes up
with some notion they don't know whether
it's going to fit the markets kind of
demand or not so p0 is going to be a
parameter that indexes the probability
that one of these entering firms is the
high type and crucially we're going to
be learning about the theatres of the
firm through consumer feedback okay so
how does this thing work so let me just
explain this this diffusion process to
you so if you look at the terms in in
black
well that is saying is that each
consumers review is a is a normally
distributed signal centered on the
underlying quality of the firm okay so
the intuition is if I go to a good
restaurant then on average I have a
better meal than if I go to a bad
restaurant okay but there's some noise
maybe I have some bad luck maybe the
chef is sick that day whatever okay so
it's just a statement about the average
experience of these firms okay but the
crucial term here is the term in red so
this lambda of T basically denotes the
rate at which reviews are being
generated for the firm okay so this is
going to be a
some of two components crucially the
first component is an endogenous sales
process okay this captures the idea that
the number of objects the firm sells in
a unit time determines how much
information is produced for that phone
okay the more consumers the firm serves
the more reviews it gets okay so
endogenous sales and then there's also a
second term which is sort of an
exogenous signal process okay this is
really a technical assumption that we
can talk more about when I get to the
equilibrium solution okay but again to
stress there's this intimate
relationship between the quantity of
sales that the firm makes and the rate
at which is getting feedback and so the
rate at which it's is rating is moving
okay so each moment in time I want to
keep track of the belief that we all
have of the firm's type okay so whether
the firm is good or bad because I only
have two state variables a sufficient
statistic for this belief is just the
posterior likelihood that the firm's
type is a high type okay based on all
the information I get from the entire
review process okay so I see all of
these reviews I form an estimate of the
firm's type and this forms a sufficient
statistic for the question oh I beg your
pardon
so this is a standard wiener process so
this just encapsulate the fact that
there is some randomness in the
experience of the consumer okay so in
particular if I just got rid of that
then we would know immediately what the
underlying type of the firm is because
if I get a good draw then it's
immediately obvious okay that just means
that it's noisy whether you have a good
meal or about meal Thanks
okay so this this expected quality is
what I'm going to call the rating of the
firm okay so I just want to make an
important and interesting distinction
between what I'm calling the rating and
what you think of as the star rating of
a offer of a firm on these markets okay
so go back to the original example if I
have one firm with five stars after one
review and one firm with five star after
a million reviews okay you would think
that the second has a high
expected quality but they have the same
star rating okay so my notion of a
rating captures this difference in
underlying quality whereas the star
rating doesn't okay
this is a massive empirical issue in in
the literature on consumer reviews and
ratings and the numbers primarily coming
in to like the customers Barry & Son I
got submitted the variance on their
readings the number like a customer is
taking into account the number of
radians so I'm not entirely sure so I
guess what I have in mind is that in
order to compute the expected quality of
the firm the star rating is insufficient
okay I need to look at the Stars and the
number of reviews
okay that's effectively what is going on
in my model right in my mind I'm doing
this computation is basically Bayes rule
right the more reviews I have that are
good the higher is the expected quality
of the phone okay put another way if
there's only one review for the firm it
doesn't really matter what that review
is in my world at least because it's so
noisy at the beginning right so that's
that's another way of putting it yes
very good no they do not they enter you
know so this is going to be a model
where firms entering and exiting or like
continuously okay so in theory I could
keep track of the exact age of the firm
it's not necessary to do so okay so as
long as I see the entire sequence of
reviews for that firm I know everything
I need to know about the firm to
computers as expected quality okay so
it's a good it's a good question but in
this model I don't need to keep track of
the age of the phone yes so in steady
state you will keep track of the vintage
of the firm no I will not that means
that if I see a small number of reviews
I'm not going to infer that it's because
it's a
I'm not going to be able to say that
it's because it's new it's a new forbids
because it has that very few sales in
the past true so so okay so very good so
that is true and again in in this model
it doesn't matter all right so to some
extent the fact that I don't have many
reviews is not indicative of so I can't
draw a distinction between a firm that's
been around for a long time and only has
three reviews and a firm that's been
around for hardly any time it has three
reviews so I'm not able to do that in
the setting that I've set up for myself
okay but that's an interesting
distinction I guess that would just make
the entry problem even harder for the
new entrant yeah right so if so if they
have lots of reviews then on average
they're going to be older of course yeah
yes definitely do you mean what I design
the the scale is this what you mean what
do you mean when we go and what's the
first best well the first best will be
such a process or is this process like
is this all tractability is this okay so
I guess two things so first best meaning
in a world where I know the underlying
type of the firm no you don't I mean
that's trivial about that world where I
every firm that comes in I know
precisely their theta then I don't need
a stochastic process I can just assign
consumers to each firm and throw out the
bad funds so in that world I don't need
any process at all the other way to I
guess answer the question is there's a
reason why I have this stochastic
process it is micro founded as an
aggregation okay so the way you want to
think about this is think about a world
in discrete time okay and in every
instance I just get a sum of random
variables so each consumer has some
outcome this random variable that's
correlated with the type of the firm
right if I take a continuous time limit
of that it's going to
- this Brownian motion yeah that's the
reason I think you don't need to just
look at the reviews from individuals
Carmen you can look at how many people
come to the restaurants of vintage and
all sort of other things so oh I beg
your home right like in my world like
yup would not need to do anything
different and will rely on this so is
this like some yeah so again I the the
reason this is coming up is because I'm
in a world where I'm just assuming that
for the time being Yelp isn't doing
anything other than posting every
reviewer gets right and in that world
this is the only stochastic process and
makes sense so later on when I do the
design problem is completely plausible
that they might want to have a whole
bunch of other things going on the age
of the firm other aspects of the like
other state variables to keep track of
the firm's quality and then I'll show
you that it doesn't is not necessary but
that that will come later okay great
thing okay terrific
so I want to do a simple application of
Bayes rule in continuous time I take the
prior belief regarding the firm's
quality I take all the information in
the signal process just one second and I
get a law of motion for how the rating
of the firm evolves in continuous time
okay so the right thing moves just a few
things to say about this the rating
moves more rapidly the more reviews I
get okay so if I'm getting lots of
reviews my rating moves faster it moves
more rapidly if each review is more
precise so that's what's that saying so
if there's an expert New York fine
critics and he's got infinite precision
he comes in these one review I know
whether the firm is good or bad okay and
also it moves more rapidly when I don't
know much about the quality of the firm
so in particular when the belief is
around 0 or 1 I'm very very certain of
what the quality of the firm is so Bayes
rule is incrementing very slowly ok I'm
updating very slowly at that point there
was a question yeah
it's not a model of adverse selection
because the firm doesn't know its type
at the point of entry very good yes so I
could talk a lot about that I'll talk a
little so there are various ways in
which you might think the firm can make
I call it intensive margin decisions
that affect the quality so Susan was and
and previously we're talking about moral
hazard right so whilst the firm is going
through its life cycle it can put effort
into affecting the quality of its output
you might think X anti-choice right so I
have to make a rather than I haven't
told you the model yet but that there
might be an investment choice ex-ante
okay short story is in virtually all of
the extensions I have where that's a
feature the main the main result of this
paper will go through so the incentive
provision is qualitatively very similar
well if you want more details about we
can talk up the offline it's a very
important question ok so the how firms
making their payoffs in this model so
they pay an entry cost to enter the
markets ok and once they're in the
markets they pay a constant operating
flow costs to remain active ok so the
restaurant has to cover its rent
irrespective of its sales what's the
revenue so in this benchmark setting the
revenue of the firm is simply equal to
the quantity of sales it makes per unit
time ok and that quantity is bound by an
exogenous capacity constraint so the
firm physically cannot sell more than at
a rate of lambda bar per unit time ok
later there will be prices very good ok
so I think of these walls as being both
relevance we've we've seen how
congestion can be issues and these
powerful are in medical medical services
I think's a great fit where prices don't
clear the market there's a bunch of
services where it's contestable whether
there are competitive prices that clear
the market products I think prices are
obviously a better fit so I want to do
both so I will do prices later ok so
firms are discounting at a rate rho and
they face a constant
hazard rates of exhaustion asleep being
killed from the market okay so I didn't
write this here but the firm is
maximizing his present discounted value
I realize we're from disparate fuel so
that this I mean this is this is how I
would do it in these sort of problems
present discounted value okay so there
are some basic assumptions here these
just ensure that the market is non-empty
okay so if the operating cost of the
firm was greater than the maximum
revenue that the firm could make in any
instant it would never make a profit so
it would never enter the market okay
similarly if the if the entry cost was
greater than the present discounted
value of selling out forever so that's
what this thing is okay if I sell out I
make that flow and discounts it forever
okay so I would never enter the market
okay because even if I sold up forever
coming into the market would be too
costly okay so very basic assumptions
what are the strategies of the firm so
they choose whether to enter the market
or not so in equilibrium what is this
going to mean it's going to mean that
there's an entry rate by firms so this
Aitor is an endogenous object this is
parts of the equilibrium fixpoint
problem and if they come in if and when
to exit the market okay so this takes
the form of a very standard optimal
stopping problem the solution to which
is an exit threshold P lower bar okay so
the firm has a state variable in my
model that state is its rating okay the
rating is going up and down depending on
the reviews that it gets if the rating
goes low enough it has to cover its rent
but it's not getting any consumers it
decides to shut down altogether okay so
that's the nature of the the solution to
the problem okay so in equilibrium I'm
gonna have a positive measure of firm so
this is a competitive market I don't
have large players I'm gonna have a
measure of small firms that are all
effectively price takers so the state
variable of the entire system is the
distribution of firms over their
idiosyncratic states okay so what I call
this is the ratings distribution at any
moment each firm is floating around in
its ray
thing but in a steady state I'm gonna
have an invariant distribution of firms
over the different rate things that they
can be on okay
and this thing is is is defined over the
the space of ratings over which firms
remain active okay so below P star the
density of firms is zero because they
will exit it have P sorry P low above
okay using an exit threshold on the
reading and not on the consumers [ __ ]
so the right thing and the posterior is
the same thing right P is what I call
the right thing but this is also the
posterior estimates at any moment of the
of the firm's quality right okay so let
me let me talk about consumers for a
second okay so my consumers let me just
do these and then I'll get right there
okay so they're they're in fixed supply
whereas the the firm's are deciding
whether to answer so their supplies
endogenous they're short lived so
they're mark they're myopic and they're
risk neutral okay so when they go to a
firm with expected quality P that's
their expected utility of consumption
okay
so here's their choice problem I call it
directed search with random rationing
for literature specific reasons so they
can see the entire ratings distribution
at any moment okay they see every firm
in the market index buys rating I it's
expected quality or its posterior that
is the state variable that they're using
to make their decision okay so again and
goes back to this point that I made
earlier then you you look at the star
rating but at least in in my model you
also combine with it the number of
reviews and both things go into your
choice of whether to go to the firm or
not okay great so let's say that a
hundred consumers turn up to a firm with
a capacity constraint of 50 then you
have a 50/50 chance of being served in
getting your expected utility of
consumption and a 50/50 chance of being
thrown out and getting nothing okay
the random rationing element of the
model so the solution to this problem is
also a threshold policy the consumers
problem is the threshold policy
okay so there's now going to be a
consumers rating threshold P star above
which consumers turn up to these firms
and they start congesting the market
okay so consumers because of their
choice problem there are no search costs
in particular they can choose any firm
in the market they have to be
indifferent between any firm that they
can choose so what happens is as the
quality of the firm gets better the
probability that I get served there goes
down because there's a whole load of
people also wanting to be served them
okay so you go to a better restaurant at
least in Manhattan you're gonna wait in
a longer queue or you have to book like
10 years in advance okay that's the
trade-off so your face in this model
another important aspect of this is that
it gives a very easy measure of consumer
surplus in my model okay P star this
threshold at which they go to is
precisely the right measure of consumer
welfare in an equilibrium why so the
guys that go to P star is served
immediately that's the definition of
this threshold so they get P star for
sure okay at any other restaurants they
have to be indifferent okay so the Q
offsets the quality so that means
consumers in expectation are getting P
star irrespective of the firm that they
go to okay so that means every consumer
is getting P star and equity room so P
star is the measure of consumer welfare
yes
mm good question no because the
distribution of the market so fix a
quantity of firms and then change the
distribution or curvature of F that
changes P star so that's the simple
answer okay pops fix a functional form
for F and just scale it all up have more
of each firm in the market then P star
goes up so you understand like more
firms in the market is good but we only
want more good firms in the market or we
can continue you can come back so in in
in some sense it's not important because
I have free entry by firms
so whatever the that well what is
important is that one site has an
exogenous measure and the other has an
endogenous measure okay so and as long
as there's free entry on one side then
the ratio is going to be the same in
equivalent so if I had put some other
constant there you would have scaled
down the entry rate linearly so in that
sense is not important but if the entry
choices by consumers and not by firms
that would change things so of course my
whole story is about the incentives for
firms so that's why I wanted to do it
this way but that's an interesting I
mean obviously consumers will make an
indulgence choice between platforms you
know
you know in a broader setting not not in
this paper yes inside yes correct there
is there an alternate version of this
where consumers have access to
sir in which case they'd be taking the
expectation on the outside right so
you'd have like I guess what's happening
here is that every customer is making
the decision based on key if I think
about the motivation that in fact
there's a lot of information that is
giving me access the posterior right and
it could have conditioned my decision on
the posterior directly and simply I
guess I'm wondering is there sufficiency
theorem somewhere that says that oh yes
[Music]
thanks sorry I was being so slow but
that that is an art none with you yes so
because of the simple like there are
various aspects of my model that allows
P to be a sufficient statistic right in
in a more general setting it would not
be so for instance if I had rather than
binary states if I had a normally
distributed state space so I had a
linear Gaussian control problem then I'd
need to keep track of an extra variable
which would be the age of the phone so
yes so this is entirely model-specific
the parlor would be I think robust to a
bunch of assumptions is the ideas that
the the entry belief is closer to the
exit threshold than the average firm so
there's this because of expo selection
the average firm is better than the
average entrant because we weed out some
of the bad phones so that I think would
be very bust but this sufficient thing
is is not that just gives me a lot of
loot so again in reality the good
question so in reality of course
consumers have idiosyncrasy and their
preferences I just wanted the simplest
model yeah I mean if we had horizontal
differentiation between consumers it
might make the entry problem even worse
because now I have to find my niche yeah
thanks okay so I just wanted to very
briefly justify why I'm closing the
consumer problem this way I think the
rest of the model lid there weren't
really any choices to make here that
were I could
in many ways I could do this so I think
this is a natural trade-off in these
platforms I hope this audience is with
me on that that I'm trading off quality
against congestion or the the wait time
of of service provision
it's very tractable for reasons that
have been made transparent and
importantly I didn't want to embed in
the model discovery frictions okay so we
talked a lot and the literature talks
about these search frictions that
consumers have just finding products in
the market these platforms help with
that ok that's not my motivation so I
didn't want to build that into the model
and give it an artificial externality
that I needed to solve with my design
problem okay so in my model consumers
can see every option in a market okay
the only thing to design is how much we
know about those options right so now I
want to delve into solve for the
equilibrium of this model I want to turn
to the firm's continuation value okay so
the stopping problem in a very standard
way can be turned into a into a
recursive problem there's a bellman
equation that's associated with the
firm's continuation problem with some
boundary conditions and whatnot so on
the x axis here is the firm state
variable so the belief will the rating
of the firm okay P star is the level of
which consumers start to turn up so
below P star my firm is making no
profits because no one's turning up in
fact it's making negative profits
because it has to cover its operating
cost an above P star its selling out
okay its selling out of capacity
immediately basically it has a bigger
and bigger Q but in this benchmark
without any prices it's not it's not
internalizing that's selling out okay
right so the fact that the firm is
learning gradually through feedback
means that the continuation problem of
the firm is is all crumbs right ten
minutes well okay let me get on with it
is is s-shaped
okay so it has this kind of funky non
concavity to it so this really is
important so I'll take a moment to
explain what's going on here so for the
high rated firms they are selling out
they don't want any feedback at all
right because therefore they're already
doing as well as they can so all the
feedback does is allow them
possibility of losing their rating and
with it all of their consumers okay so
that's why their problem is concave the
closer they get to this threshold the
the more their continuation is eroded
because they might lose all their
consumers on the other hand the the low
rated firms have a convex problem
because they're not getting any profits
the only way they get profits is by
getting a high enough rating so they
want a lot of feedback immediately okay
either it tells me I'm really crap and I
should just leave the market or it tells
me I'm good and I'm gonna get a lot of
profits okay so where SCM so this is the
continuation problem the firm the HIV
problem so whereas the the low rated
firms want a lot of information and the
high rated firms don't in equilibrium
it's precisely the reverse that's going
on okay the high rated firms are getting
a lot of consumer feedback because
that's where all the consumers are
turning up and under full transparency
that's where they're all leaving their
reviews okay the low rated firms are
getting very little they're just ticking
alonger this exogenous background raise
okay so this is the what I would call
the miss allocation in the firms problem
that is going to tell us exactly what to
do when we get to the design pond okay
so just keep this in mind
yes yes right so epsilon I have this
little eggs or tunas signal process so
in particular very good if I didn't have
that P star would be equal to P lower
bar all right as soon as I lose all my
consumers I just leave the market so
it's some technical steady state reasons
why I want this region here but also I
do want some reasons in my model why
consumers turn up to firms that are
independent of their rating as as some
do right they they don't get to choose
they're just impatient they go to the
first but they don't use a platform full
stop right so I want some people like
that though they leave reviews
nonetheless okay so the ratings
distribution so I think I
hmm yeah I think I'm gonna skip this so
there's some very interesting aspects of
the Racing's distribution that turns up
in equilibrium the main empirical
prediction is that it's about the tail
parameter of the distribution so if you
know about burrito tails this
distribution has a fatter right tail
than it does left tail okay so that's a
robust prediction of the model I did a
little empirical section in the paper
that I absolutely don't have time to
talk about right now there has some
evidence that this is in fact what's
going on at least in the setting that I
tested using Yelp dates and restaurants
okay but summarizing under this
benchmark of full transparency we get a
unique steady state our stationary
libram it's unique features positive
rates of entry rates of exit and is this
congestion of the highest rates of firms
in the market okay more predictions of
the model I I think I'm going to skip
over this this is just here to convince
us that this is the right positive
theory to be looking at because there
are plenty of predictions that that
validate the model a lot of these have
been studied in the literature already
in the empirical literature I've done
definitely skipping this this is just a
technical description of what's how
equilibria ms defined anyone who's
interested in mean field games come and
ask me afterwards happy to talk about it
offline okay but the important part here
is to talk about ratings design so now
I'm going to think of a platform whose
objective in my world is consumer
welfare okay so there's a very
interesting discussions that we have
about what the right objective is think
of this as a first parcel of normative a
normative exercise so I care about
consumer welfare for various reasons
where there I be a regulator or a
platform this is this is the objective
I'm gonna take and remember consumer
welfare is just its equilibrium object P
star right so I want to maximize the P
star associated with my design policy
that's the aim of the game I should
point out that because my firms are
making zero profits in equilibrium
actually consumer welfare is equal to
overall welfare all right but I'd like
you to think more about consumer welfare
thing but more importantly the
instrument that I'm allowing my designer
to to optimize over is a filtering of
the review process to shape the way the
ratings evolve for for the firm okay so
in particular I can exclude or include
reviews and this changes the rate at
which the firm's rating is updated okay
I think I want to skip a lot of the
technicalities here because I'm really
running short on time the policies that
I'm looking at in words do the following
at any instant the platform gets let's
say 10 reviews in for that firm as a
function of the current rating of the
firm it can suppress some fraction of
those reviews okay so for instance it
doesn't have to put any of them into the
rating and so the rating would be
constant or it could put them all in and
update the right thing okay that is in
words that set of policies on looking at
in particular full transparency belongs
to this class okay by setting the
suppression rate equal to 0 okay
I don't suppress any of them so I like
this class because there has you know
appealing features there would be easy
to implement they're very easy to study
for me technically just one thing I
would say that certification is when
above a certain rating I don't include
any new reviews at all so this is like
giving that firm a badge they get that
rating forever and they don't and they
sort of keep this badge yes very good
this is a commitment policy I'm not
doing that's a good review I included
that's a bad review I've done ok it's a
black box I have 10 reviews I don't know
their realizations I just decide I pick
some fraction of them randomly as it's a
it's not obvious whether they're it's
not obvious that it you would think so
my let's talk more after afterwards it's
it's not obvious so it needs a
discussion yeah consumers are aware of
the policy if they're away absolutely so
my consumers are extremely rational I
realized that this is a different so
they they can compute every equilibrium
object perfectly an expectation okay so
this is a rational expectations
equilibrium okay so this is the main
takeaway from the from the benchmark
setting the optimal rating policy is I
didn't even define this thing it's it's
all-or-nothing so what this means in
words is above the equilibrium consumers
rating I don't release any information
at all
below the rating I release every review
that comes through okay so that was what
my definition of all-or-nothing is okay
so five minutes
i mean--you how many minutes we have oh
my god okay okay
rounding up excellent so I think the
easiest way to think about this is the
following so the ratings policy provides
incentives for firms in two different
ways firstly the policy shapes where
consumers go and hence which firms are
making profits secondly the policy
shapes how fast it takes me to to move
through the writing space okay so it
changes the curvature of my continuation
problem okay now what the platform wants
to do because is thinking of consumer
surplus is maximize P star right by
pushing P star up I'm screwing my firm's
because they don't get to make profits
until they're a lot older right when P
star goes up on average they're older
okay so this is depressing incentives
for firms I need to compensate them
because ultimately I want a lot of firms
in my markets okay as I was having this
discussion earlier the more firms in the
market typically the better our
consumers off because the capacity
constraint means you know if I have 10
good firms now I have a hundred good
firms that's great okay because I
conserve all of my consumers at the best
place in time okay so I want more firms
in the market but I'm depressing their
incentives by increasing P star so what
do I have to do I have to think about
this other channel of providing
incentives for the firm's I have to
design the ratings policy to maximize
the speed of which they're going through
their ratings and incentivize them to
participate okay now we remember from
the firm's problem that what they wanted
was fast slow remember that whereas what
they got was slow fast okay so
this policy is basically doing the best
thing for firms in in that dimension
it's slowing down reviews at the top
stimulating more firms to come in
because this is good for them and thus
improving consumer welfare okay so I'm
afraid I don't have time to talk about
prices at all I better use tell me one
minute
so now just I I don't have time ready to
talk about prices simple takeaway is
certification is going to be better than
transparency okay so we still want to
have this kind of region at the top
where we're not providing firms with
information okay so and no details
unfortunately so summary is there's this
barrier it's the entry problem for these
firms because of incomplete information
I studied the design problem of looking
at ratings and the optimal policy
involves throwing away reviews for
incumbents in order to give new entrants
a better shot at penetrating the market
more applications for future work okay
thanks a lot
yes Thursday yes so so your customers
are homogenius right and so if you have
children et among your customers then
you know and you don't control the
matching as it's not for so you could
potentially you know but matches for me
right
you would have like by the quality being
much too low quality firm so this have a
sense of how yeah good yeah
suppose that your objective as a
platform and a similar question it's not
consumer welfare but overall you know
like an overall profit that the first
make because you can Ricardo so on the
on the on the first point I think
there's still an entry problem in the
following sense so now let's say that
the the low type firms actually generate
value so now the firm's problem looks a
little bit like a you right when
known to be low there's a whole section
of consumers that actually likes that at
the beginning I still don't know what
kind of firm I am okay so there's still
this issue of trying to reveal what type
of firm there is through the feedback
the exit problem becomes more aligned
with the entry problem in some ways okay
so you know there I might decide to
leave immediately because people want to
know whether I'm a hipster cafe or not
and they have horizontal preferences for
that but until they know they you know
so I think the entry margin is still
pretty problematic even in that world so
the second question different objective
functions this is obviously a very
important question so like I said
overall surplus the the same thing goes
through if I'm looking at a commission
on prices just on so on transactions on
prices okay so I take the price of a
transaction and I take a fraction of
that away it can go either way
okay because on the one hand now the
platform doesn't like competition by
firms it wants only a few firms they get
to corner the market and I can extract
more surplus on the other hand if I
charge a flat fee per transaction so I
want to maximize the the not like the
average quality then my policy is still
optimal okay exactly exactly so again I
think a more encyclopedic treatment of
objectives is beyond is beyond this but
that's that's my intuition for that yeah
right yeah so I tell you what not quite
so the intuition is the same in the
sense that I don't want them to amass a
big stock of reviews and so by lobbing
them off at the beginning I keep their
stock bounded so two reasons why that's
different one well not different but the
reason it doesn't have a role here is
because for my firms have a fixed type
throughout their life so different
vintages of reviews are equally
informative right so
No then it doesn't change they don't
change they don't change exactly so if I
mean right so in any world where there's
moral hazard or there's some evolving
type I want to lob off earlier reviews
would be the same value if you hide
right totally sorry right right so if my
objective was being realistic then I'd
have to have that there are just a bunch
of papers that look at that margin and
so I didn't want to have it in there
without a story to be telling everyone
sorry I'm gone I've gone over okay so we
have a break now John Horton
unfortunately had a cancel just a couple
days back and Steve told me to take this
slot so I did but what I would say is
there's coffee outside and if you see my
talk before well you won't really wanted
to see John you can just you're not
going to see John but you can come back
tomorrow at 9:00 a.m. okay if not I'm
going to be speaking here at 3:45 okay
[Applause]